AND NOW IT'S TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
#HASHTAGWARS.
IN HONOR OF OUR ESTEEMED COMIC
BOOK STORE OWNER TURNED
PANELIST KEVIN SMITH,
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS
#HIPSTERCOMICBOOKS. EXAMPLES
WOULD BE SOMETHING LIKE
BAT MEH, OR V FOR VEGAN, OR
CY-CURIOUS-CLOPS.
I'M PUTTING 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND GO.
JEN KIRKMAN.
>> I'M A MUSICIAN.
I'VE NEVER SWUNG A BAT, MAN.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, GOOD, POINTS, I
LIKE IT.
KEVIN.
>> THE PABST.
>> CHRIS: GOOD, POINTS.
I GOT IT.
JEN.
>> CAT EYE GLASS WOMAN.
>> CHRIS: OKAY, YEAH, YEAH.
JUSTIN.
>> THE FARMER'S MARKETEER.
>> CHRIS: GOOD, POINTS.
GOOD JOB.
JUSTIN.
>> THE SILVER LAKE SURFER.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS! KEVIN.
>> I'M GOING TO GO WITH MUMFORD
AND RED SONS OF KRYPTON.
>> CHRIS: ANOTHER GOOD, POINTS.
KEVIN.
>> SPIDER COMMA MAN.
>> CHRIS: JUSTIN.
>> THE BARISTA!
>> CHRIS: YES.
( APPLAUSE )
POINTS.
JEN.
>> I DON'T OWN AN IRON, MAN.
DAMNIT. IT STILL WORKS.